je suis un bâtard ouais ça c'est évident
et vous et vous pourrez vous vous aussi
vous êtes patat
dans les minutes vous pouvez prendre à
cette question vous même d'être chauve
c'est pas trop mal alors j'aimerais vous
raconter deux petites histoires la
première un chasse à l'ours il ya
quatorze mille ans pas loin d'ici
la chaux-de-fonds jura suisse il était
une fois un jeune chasseur de 20 ans qui
l'a suivi à l'os et enfin il avait eu
six de le tirer avec son app des flèches
et c'est un bon chasseur l'a tiré dans
le cou et la flèche a coupé un grandes
artères et places et le losc a
grièvement
c'est prenantes l'osce a pu se retirer
dans une petite grotte à loin petit côté
15 m de profondeur l'eau c'était tout au
fond les jeunes chasseurs l'aspirine
prudemment mais quand même il a un
allumé un feu à l'entrée de la grotte
pour l'info mais pour le sortir des
centres refuge cet ours ne bougeait plus
donc enfin il son approche
quand même un peu trop tôt parce que
avec un dernière dernier geste
l'animal inflige un coup mortel sur
l'épaule droite de cette jeune homme et
les deux secondes sur place alors bien
sûr
quatorze mille ans plus tard en 1956
d'espérer locke de la chaux-de-fonds ont
trouvé les deux squelettes entremêlés
comme à l'époque ce n'était pas évident
il ya liaison le squelette de l'osce
étaient déposées au musée d'histoire
naturelle à la chaux de fonds et le
squelette de l'homme un truc à quelle
logique était déposée au musée
d'archéologie cantonal de neuchâtel qui
s'appelle maintenant l'atteignons où
vous pouvez visiter cet homme du
biscione alors prendre cinq ans plus
tard un archéologue de la chaux-de-fonds
a travaillé dans les tiroirs et tout à
coup il a remarqué un pointe sèche dans
l'artère cervicale de ses courses et là
la liaison entre l'os et l'ont été
établi bon dans la presse à l'époque or
nous ont parlé de notre plus vieux
ancêtres et les premiers chèques sont
fondées est-ce que c'est frais c'est ce
qu'ont plus savoir s'il s'agit vraiment
de notre plus ancien ancêtre
oui
maintenant on les peu grâce aux études
l'adn pendant les petites dix à quinze
camions année l'analyste de l'adn et
surtout de l'ancien aden en fait
d'énormes progrès complètement
bouleversé notre connaissance de l'umac
de l'histoire de l'humanité en 2013
un groupe de vingt ans les chercheurs
européens où je fais partie ont analysé
l'adn de l'homme dijon puis deux
individus de chasseurs cueilleurs et
cocasse en géorgie puis d autres
individus des populations anciennes
qu'est ce qu'on a trouvé l'adn de
l'homme du bichon on trouve pas plus du
tout dans les populations de l'europe du
sud à prendre le plus haut non on va on
trouve de plus en plus tandis que de
gènes des deux crocs casiers sont
repartis pondent dans toute l'europe
occidentale et c'est pas tout
aujourd'hui dans la population
européenne actuelle on trouve encore la
vienne de trois populations anciennes
des plus comment expliquer ce ça alors
cela je dois commencer plus tôt il y à
60 mille ans l'homme anatomiquement
modernes chez nous se disperser de
l'afrique vers le proche orient où il a
rencontré l'homme de néandertal et bien
sûr ils ont eu envie
c'est à dire envie de se reproduire
parce que ça c'est une caractéristique
et tous les êtres vivants donc des et
mélanger et après cette petite épisode
amoureux l'homme anatomiques modernes
s'est dispersée vers l'europe vers
l'asie en remplaçant tous les nains
total puis en australie et plus tard en
amérique du nord et du sud
alors la population qui se disperser en
europe et celle à laquelle appartiennent
de l'homme de pichon mais cette
population ne pas rester comme il est et
on a un grand apport génétique d'un
groupe on appelle eurasien ancien du
nord de plus on a un autre groupe qui
s'appelle yann maia qui a apporté
beaucoup des jeunes dans la population
européenne
les annales
ils ont vécu au nom de mr marc dans les
steppes pratique ils ont pratiqué
surtout le pastoralisme est un peu
d'agriculture et c'est à travers de ce
groupe
nous avons reçu la dn2 les deux
caucasiens parce que les chasseurs
cueilleurs du caucase ils ont laissé
leurs empreintes génétiques sur les
gammes nay
mais l'histoire ne s'arrête pas ici si
on regarde la répartition spatiale des
certains gènes l'image est tout autant
complexe ce principe rentrer maintenant
une liste j'ai préparé
le tellement complexe si on regarde le
gène qui permette l'adaptation à
l'altitude de la population du tibet on
trouve que ça vienne de notre ancien
groupe qui s'appelle dennis hopper
alors ce groupe on connaît seulement
chez les 10 mots parce que on a trouvé
seulement une petite phalange dans une
grotte en sibérie qui s'appelle grotte
de des liserés mais dans les populations
d océanie c'est en papouasie
nouvelle-guinée australie des polynésie
ils ont encore les plus grande partie de
l'adn de dix hommes à prendre les
replace la population française on
trouve très peu d adn de dennis hopper
comme contre-pouvoir probablement savent
le gène responsable pour la digestion de
la capacité de digérer le lait à l'âge
adulte ne pas reprendre de manière
homogène à travers le monde alors en
allemagne et en anglais angleterre et au
nord de la france
90 % des adultes portent ce jeune dont
peuvent digérer le lait au sud de la
france seulement 30 60 au sud afrique et
dans le sud de l'asie est moins que dix
présente dans le nord de l'australie 20
passante au milieu de l'australie 30
présente au sud de l'australie et en
tasmanie 50 60 à l'ouest de l'afrique
oui moi je dirais cette liste était
probablement déjà trop longue et vous
pouvez déjà répondre à ma question
initiale et vous vous êtes bâtard aussi
très bien compris donc être un bâtard il
n'y a pas de quoi avoir honte de même
être un bâtard il n'y a pas de quoi être
fier c'est tout simplement la chose la
plus normale et je peux vous assurer
qu'il n'a pas une seule personne qui
n'en est pas
[Applaudissements]